Why is millennial humor SO WEIRD?
(quietly)I don't get these memes
Ha-ha!
Joke's on you dad
*disturbing sound*
You don't understand this joke
Well I understand every single level of meme intricacy of this
Hah! You think you're so smart, huh?
*disturbing sound*
Is this loss?
hahaha
Oh, you don't understand
don't you?
Oh, you can't be part of my little secret joke club now
Yeah, I watch Marvel
(reading) M A R V E
*disturbing sound* I hit 3 dogs everyday son
*disturbing sound*
Why is millennial humor so weird?!
Just don't get it. What's funny about a cartoon?
*disturbing sound*
You have been visited by a dog
So WHAT?
Where's the punchline?
*disturbing sound*
How am I supposed to haa
if I don't know what the joke is?
Why is millennial humor so weird? What am I even looking at?
*disturbing sound*
Why does it look so weird?
Why is Markiplier's face photoshopped on top of Wee sport?
whY*DISTURBING SOUND*
I don't get it!
*disturbing sound*
Ah... What is this?
Why is millennial humor so weird?
👏*disturbing sound*👏
Meme review everybody! Youtube's favorite show where I explain the joke
therefore ruining the joke, therefore killing the meme
I'm your hoes
You may have seen a Lord Farquaad with Markiplier photoshopped on top of it saying E
Now the joke here, it is so funny! Just wait until I explain it
But first let's review the meme.
For some reason it's just a meme to photoshop Mark's face
on top of the fa-he-he-ce
with Lord Farquaad's
...based body. It looks good!
Like, I'm strangely arou- eh- not arouse... that's a bit far
Could it be the perfect match of the squared faces that they both have?
I'm- I'm not gonna call Mark short, because I'm- people call me short when it's not true.
You know, there's a discrimination in the short community.
But here's a little of less than average... height. Let's just say that
Literally you need to be an intellectual to understand this meme
Now, of course, the more than indistinguishable this meme is - the better it gets
Just, wait until you hear the joke, guys. It's gonna be great
This meme has now become the...
Oh- the joy- the millennial humor is so weird. Before he used to be like hah so straightforward
Memes then:
Movie in jamaica. Am I a pirate of the Caribbean?
Hmmmm 🤔
Memes now:
*disturbing sound*
!EEE!
It started from photoshop from Cyndago!
It makes me so uncomfortable just looking at thi-hi-is 🤣
1950 in the future: I bet literature and culture-
I can't read. I forgot my contact lenses. Don't make fun of my glasses, guys. Okay? I don't like wearing them
I bet literature and culture will have advanced to be greater than ever before
2018:
*disturbing sound*
!EEEEE!
I'd be seeing a lot of these popping up and left and right
Opens a package and sets the box aside
My cat: it's free real estate
Hahaha. I understand because I know the quote!
This is another perfect example how memes are just hieroglyphic
No, one's gonna know what the f this means one day
Yes that's right. It's not like
communications and the way we store it information in general had improve
Instead beyond writing things on walls
Ha-ha. We're so quirky am I right? I hate this!
This tumblr-ish type of humor of like: hehe we're so random right now guys
Ha-ha
You're ruining this meme!
I'm sorry
aaAaaAAAAaaAaAAAa
!E!
Why is it funny? I DON'T KNOW
*beauliful calm music*
What a beautiful E... Blessed be thy E
oh my God
*beauliful calm music*
I get it now
I understand the humor
Before millennial jokes were so weird but I get it now. Eee
EEE, of course!
OF COUR-
How can I've been so blind?!
!EEEEEE!
!EEeeeEEEeEEeeEeE!
*song*
A for apple, A for ant
Ah Ah AAA
*silly Felix's voice on the background*
B for-
Let's just cut to the punchline 🤣🤣🤣
D for dots
Duu-tu-tuu
E for-
*echo*
Eee
🤣🤣🤣
To E, or not to E? That is the question!
WALL- EeE!
mc square- of course
... equals E. That's right.
Oh, wow! I can barely see this one!
That means it's extra funnyEee
do-do do-do
to-to-do-to
TO-DO-DO
EEE
E versus B - the ultimate battle. Which meme will win? Which meme will conquer?
Hmm
👏 👏
This meme gets, of course, an
*disturbing sound*
E - rating
I would rate this an 8. Cuz it's pretty funny.
It makes me laugh.
But the tumblr-ish group of 'haha we're so perky. Look, no one gets this!'
ruins it. So i'm gonna have to give it a 2
I'm sorry, Mark
👏 👏
*boom*
*lit*
My ass / Spicy chicken curry
This doesn't work. You need Coca-Cola light. Everyone is keep posting this meme...
and a- me an intellectual, clearly. It doesn't work. You need to use Coca-Cola light. You can't use regular Coke
It might work a little bit, but not as effective
And if you want the meme to work, at least, be factually correct with your meme. Please.
This has been meme correction
👏 *meme*  👏 *correction*
Do it again and do it right
Mom says: Despacito.
The Despacito meme has been going on for a long time. I know everyone's gonna be like
*noisy poods*
HeY bUt i aLReAdY kNOw aBouT ThiS mEme FEliX sO I'm aLrEAdY- SHTHFKUP
Everyone that writes mean comments about meme review I- I have your data
I will find you and I will physically harm you
Now I know what you're all thinking
Why has there not been a Despacito 2 yet? Huh?
Why? What is taking so long?
Donald Trump tweeted: Despacito 2 coming this fall
HOORAY!
Suicide rate drops- to 0
WOW
Dear liberals,
Despacito Neighborino
WHY IS MILLENNIAL HUMOR so weird?
I don't get. It's so crazy.
Despacito 3 found on Mars!
Heck, yes! So, Despacito 3 confirmed as well. But where is Despacito 2?
Dear liberals,
Despacito
The ultimate argument winner. It's taken over from
'no you'
Just- just hit him with a despacito. It works every time.
Fortnite collabs with Despacito!
YES, all my favorite things are collaborating!
I love that! Are- there's a lot of positivity in spread across the world
EMINEM
deconfirms Despacito fou- 7
*sad music*
Eminem
more like
Emilem
*sad music*
God i hate-
Despacito 2 will be delayed. DAMMIT
Elom Musk buys and then deletes Despacito
Stalin releases Despacito 17
Despacito 2 confirmed by NASA
Despacito 7 announced at E3
Nolan will direct Despacito 4. That's great.
Oh my God, that would be so cool
Like a really knit gritty and dark Despacito. Can you imagine that?
For now I would say this is sort of a
prequel meme
It's sort of a
can we get orange boy into Fortnite type of meme?
But the meme will, I think, when it thrives is- if Despacito 2 actually comes out
It wouldn't surprise me at this point. It's the most viewed song on Youtube of all time.
If they make a Despacito 2, they will make history.
I need a Despacito 2. I don't think I can live any longer
without a Despacito 2.
This meme gets a
👏  👏
10 out of 10 because I need Despacito 2 so badly
Is there any way I can inject Despacito in my bloodstream, in my veins, in my skeleton, in my DNA?
Let me know. Hook me up in the comments.
I know the power of patriarchy. I know what men can do when they're angry
!!!WWWHHRRRRRREEEEEEEEEEEE!!!
And now, this...
and now
EEEEEEEEEEEE
BONUS M-
*loses bracelet*
*realisation*
*whisper*
bonus meme
Bonus meme this week. Finally. It's been so long
it'sbeensolong
I'm shaking. I'm shaking, guys
Instead of saying no
we can now instead just say 'yesn't'
That's right if you're an absolute batum a SOY boy that can't face with any type of confrontation
Instead of saying 'no' you can now just say 'yesn't'!
Yesn't, yesn't I do no- don't you want to do tha- 🤣 🤣
Instead of saying 'nope', inspare yourself and saying 'nah',
or 'nahhen', or 'noyep', or 'noppen', or 'anti yes', 'opposite yes'.
Just. Say. YESN'T!
There's of course ways to use this same principle in your everyday life.
Instead of playing communism, just say foodn't
Nurse: sir, you've been in a coma since 2017
Do people still use this meme format?
Nurse: yesn't
If NO can be yesn't
and yes can be non't
then yes can be yes'nt'nt
and no can be no'nt'nt
Men
Men't
🤣🤣🤣
This is a sexism, okay? Why can't there be' woman' and 'womann't', huh?
*applause*
👏👏👏👏👏👏
Yes
Yeah
Yah
Nahyeah! 🤣 🤣
Non't, everybody
Non't
Change all stop signs to gon't signs
Come on, guys. If we can get a hundred times this will actually happen
Let's do it together for the epic meme, guys. As a community! Yeah, we're so quirky!
Cross
Croissn't
SO LAME!
Doggo
Doggn't
🤔 Hmm 🤔
Dead
LIFEN'T! 🤣
👏  👏
This meme gets a zeron't
Everybody
See what I did there? Absolutely hilarious!
Make sure it smash that like button. Can we hit it fifty thousandn't?
🤔 🤔 🤔
*is that right?*
*non't*
👏 meme 👏 review everybody
Youtube's favorite show
I'm your host
Jacksepticeyen't